i have a list of numbers here and my
goal over the course of this video is to
actually order these numbers or i guess
think of it order these quantities
however you want to view it and some of
these are expressed as percentages this
one and this one over here sum is pure
decimals and some of these is fractions
and this fraction right here is a proper
fraction and this right here is a mixed
number and there's a bunch of ways you
can order it you could just get an
intuitive sense of roughly how large
this is and try to order it that way or
you could put it all in the exact same
format and then compare it directly and
at least for me the easiest format to
put these all in and that makes the
comparisons easy would be to put them
all into a decimal format so
35.7 percent
35
point seven
percent is literally the same thing as
35.7
per hundred percent per percent sent for
a hundred so it's literally the same
thing as 35.7 over 100 or this is the
same thing as dividing 35.7 by a hundred
and when you divide something by
let me do it this way if i have 35 i'm
doing that same color actually if i have
35.7
if i have 35.7 if i divide it by 10 i'm
going to move the decimal place over to
the left once 35.7 divided by 10 is 3.57
if i divide it by a hundred i'm going to
move the decimal to the left one more
time so if you divide this by a hundred
you get
the decimal is in front of the three now
point three five seven i'll put the zero
out here just to make sure that we know
where the decimal is and all of that so
you take 35.7 divided by 100 you get
0.357
now let's think about
108.1 percent
108.15
108.1 percent the same thing it's the
same thing as 108.1
divided by 100 and this is the same
thing as
108.1 if you divide by 10 you're going
to move the decimal to the left once if
you divide by 100 you're going to move
the decimal to the space to the you're
going to move the decimal to the left
twice that's the decimal is going to end
up right over here so this is the same
thing as 1.0
1.081
and so it's clearly greater and
obviously these were both in percentage
i didn't have to conv convert them to
realize that 35.7 percent is smaller
than 108.1 percent but now we have them
both in decimals
this 0.5 already in a decimal we don't
have to convert it
0
0.5
then we have 13
90 thirds or 13 over 93 and the easiest
way to convert this to a decimal is
literally perform the division 13 90
thirds is the same thing as 13 divided
by 93 so let's figure out what that is
let's divide
93
into 93 into 13 and this number is going
to be smaller than 1 13 is smaller than
93 so this number is going to be smaller
than 1 so we're going to have definitely
things to the right of a decimal point
so i'm going to add i added some
trailing zeros here to the 13 didn't
change its value and i'm going to put
the decimal right up there
and you say 93 goes into 13 well it
doesn't go into 1 it doesn't go into 13
but it does go into 130.
93 goes into 130
one time
and 1 times 93 is 93 and now we can
subtract and you could do this in your
head 130 minus 93 that's 37 because 130
minus 100 would be 30 and then you got 7
more to get to 93 or if you want you
could do it by regrouping you could say
well let me take one away from this 3
so that becomes a 2 and it's in the tens
place so i really is really i took a 10
away from it and i'm regrouping it into
the ones place
so this becomes a 10. and for the sake
of just this mini computation you
shouldn't be thinking about this decimal
right over here we're really viewing
this as 130 minus 93.
and so if 10 minus 3 is 7
and then you could do this as 12 minus 9
which would be 3 or if you want to do it
more formally you could say look 2 minus
9 i don't want to i don't want to
subtract a larger number from a smaller
number so let me borrow 1 from the
hundreds place
and i give that to the tens place but
i'm really borrowing 100 100 represented
in the tens place is 10
10 plus 2 is 12. that's really what
we're doing but 12 minus 9 is
3. so that's where we get our 37
bring down
bring down another zero how many times
does 93 go into 370 it looks like it
would go about three times
three times three times three is nine
three times
3 times 9 is 27
and when we subtract
we get
let's see we want to borrow one from the
tens place so this would become 10 this
would become a 6 we're really regrouping
a 10 and just and writing it in the tens
place so it looks like so in the ones
place now so it's a 10. and so 10 minus
9 is 1. now we have a 6 here we don't
want to do 6 minus 7. so let's regroup
again
let's take a 100 from the hundreds place
put in the tens place so that's really
becomes ten tens ten plus six is sixteen
or if you think about it we're borrowing
a one sixteen minus seven is nine and
then we have sorry this is a two right
here two minus two is 0. so we're just
left with a 91. and then we could put a
we can bring down another zero here
bring down another zero 93 goes into 910
nine times i believe and let's try it
out three times 9 or 9 times 3 is 27
is 27
and then 9 times 9 is 81 plus 2 is 83
and we can keep going here we can keep
going here let's see z we can't won't
want to subtract the seven from the zero
so let's borrow one from the tens place
this becomes a zero this becomes a ten
ten minus seven is three and then we go
to the tens place zero minus three don't
wanna do that borrow one from the
hundreds place this becomes an eight
this becomes a ten ten minus three is
seven eight minus eight is nothing so
we're left with a remainder of seventy
three and we can keep going we can keep
adding digits here but i think this is
enough for us to make the comparison so
13 over 93 13 90 thirds
is equal to
0.139 and we can keep going and adding
and adding more decimals to this
now finally we have 1 and 7 68 there's a
couple of ways to think about it you
could just figure out what 7 68 is as a
decimal and add that to 1 or we can
rewrite this as an improper fraction and
then write that as a decimal so we could
just to get the practice let's write
this as an improper fraction so 1 and 7
68 i'll do it over here 1 and 7 68 is
the same thing as 1 plus 7 over 68 which
is the same thing as 68 over 68 plus 7
over 68. i really just found a common
denominator 1 is the same thing as 68
over 68.
and so this is equal to now that we have
a common denominator
over 68 68 plus 7 is 75 so if we want to
write it as a mixed number it is 75 over
68 and now we can literally just divide
75 by 68 and figure out what it is
expressed as a decimal and then we can
put it in order
and so let's try it out and we can also
you know just look at the numbers if
we're trying to do this as quickly as
possible you can sometimes just estimate
well gee how how large is it compared to
the other things well this thing is
definitely going to be over one so it's
definitely larger than this guy
definitely larger than this guy and
definitely larger than this guy
not super clear whether it's definitely
larger than this guy over here this 1.08
i suspect it will be but let's verify
so we're going to divide we're going to
divide 75 by 68 so we're going to divide
68
into 75 and we care about what happens
after the one so let's add some
zeros to the right of the decimal spot
68 goes into 75 one time 1 times 68 is
68 and then we subtract
then we subtract
and we have a let's see 5 minus 8 we're
going to need to regroup or borrow let's
make this a 15 we're borrowing or
regrouping from the tens place this is
just a six
fifteen minus eight is seven
bring down a zero sixty-eight goes into
seventy
one time so we actually already have
done enough to figure out how this
compares to this number up here we know
that if we keep going you know 1 times
68 is 68 we subtract we get 2 here bring
down another
0 68 doesn't go into it doesn't go to 20
at all it goes into it 0 times and so we
already see it's at least 1.10 and then
we're going to keep going as we keep
dividing but we see that this value is
already already greater than the 1.08
1.081 so if we really want need to order
these numbers this is the largest so
i'll write it i'll order it this way the
largest is 1 and 7 68. the next largest
was this 1.081 which in its original
form
was
108.1 percent the next largest after
that
is this 0.5
the next largest after that is the 0.5
and then we have the 0.357 which was the
same thing as a 35.7 percent
35.7 percent and then finally the
smallest value was the 13 over 93.
13 over 93. now i did this i went
through all of the work and i divided
them all out i converted them all to
decimals but when you're just purely
ordering the numbers it's sometimes a
good idea or maybe if you do if you're
if you're constrained for time you might
want to estimate for example like right
over here you could say look this thing
is definitely greater than one so the
only thing that kind of competitive with
it for the top spot is this right over
here and the way i thought about it is
that this when we write wrote this as a
mixed number when we wrote this as a
mixed number this is 75 over 60.
actually think of it this way we don't
even have to write as a mixed number 7
68 7 over 70 would be 0.1 so this is
more than 0.1 because we have a smaller
denominator over here so this is going
to be greater than 1.1 this is going to
be greater than 1.1 just estimating it
just looking at it right over there
and so that would have given you a good
sense look that's going to be greater
than this which is 1.08 so that would
have helped you order this is the
largest this is the second largest then
it's pretty obvious that this is less
than a half and this is less than a half
this would have to be 50 percent to be
less than a half so then you'd put the
0.5
and then 35.7
that still 35.7 percent is greater than
a third 13 is less than a third of 93 a
third of 93 would be 31 and so you could
say well the next smallest or the next
largest i guess or the next smallest
down going in in descending order would
be the 35.7 percent and then finally the
13 over 93. so if your goal is just to
order it that's a completely valid way
of doing it it would actually take you a
little less time